Ana: En la primera taza dejamos a Costa Rica como provincia marginal, con cabildos, costumbre y una relación muy pragmática con la ley. Hoy la pregunta es otra: ¿qué pasa cuando llega la independencia?
Mateo: Pasa algo curioso: Costa Rica no conquista la independencia con una épica militar propia. La recibe. La declaración se produce en Guatemala el 15 de septiembre de 1821 y la noticia llega después al territorio costarricense.
Ana: Esa independencia recibida cambia el tono del nacimiento político. No hay un ejército libertador reclamando poder ni una ruptura heroica que ordene el relato. Hay incertidumbre, cabildos, pueblos deliberando y mucha cautela institucional.
Mateo: Por eso el Pacto de Concordia es tan importante. Es el primer documento constitucional costarricense, adoptado por representantes de Cartago, San José, Heredia y Alajuela. Un nombre precioso, además: concordia, no conquista.
Ana: Y sin embargo la concordia no eliminó el conflicto. El pacto tenía una ambigüedad sobre la anexión al Imperio Mexicano de Iturbide. Cartago tendía a la anexión; San José defendía una salida republicana.
Mateo: Esa tensión desemboca en Ochomogo, el primer conflicto armado interno. Gana San José y con eso se consolida la orientación republicana. También se desplaza el centro político desde Cartago hacia San José.
Ana: Me interesa que la disputa no era solo geográfica. Era una pregunta sobre el tipo de comunidad política: ¿seguimos vinculados a una monarquía imperial o ensayamos una república pequeña, frágil, pero propia?
Mateo: Luego viene la Federación Centroamericana. Costa Rica entra en 1824 a un proyecto liberal y regional, pero la Federación fracasa por distancia, conflictos provinciales y falta de identidad común. El sueño centroamericano no desaparece, pero no logra hacerse Estado efectivo.
Ana: En ese periodo aparecen instituciones tempranas: organización judicial, Casa de la Moneda, imprenta. No son adornos. Son piezas materiales de soberanía: administrar justicia, producir moneda, imprimir normas y argumentos.
Mateo: Y luego aparece Braulio Carrillo, una figura inevitablemente ambigua. Constructor del Estado moderno para unos; autócrata para otros. Su Ley de Bases y Garantías de 1841 centraliza, profesionaliza y ordena, pero concentra mucho poder en el Ejecutivo.
Ana: Carrillo suprime cabildos y reemplaza la lógica municipal por funcionarios nombrados desde la capital. Es casi el choque entre el mundo colonial de arreglos locales y el Estado moderno que quiere hablar con una sola voz.
Mateo: Ahí se ve una tensión recurrente: para construir Estado hay que crear autoridad; pero si se concentra demasiado, el constitucionalismo liberal se incomoda. Costa Rica aprende temprano que eficiencia y libertad no siempre caminan al mismo ritmo.
Ana: Después llega la declaración formal de la República en 1848, con José María Castro Madriz. Es un acto jurídico y simbólico: Costa Rica se afirma como república soberana, con bandera, escudo y lenguaje propio de Estado.
Mateo: Y pocos años después, la Campaña Nacional contra William Walker se convierte en momento fundacional de identidad. La guerra no crea solo victoria militar; crea una imaginación nacional que supera identidades locales.
Ana: Juan Rafael Mora Porras queda ahí como figura trágica: lidera la defensa nacional y luego es derrocado y fusilado. La misma élite cafetalera que el Estado estaba ayudando a consolidar podía volverse contra el gobernante.
Mateo: El republicanismo temprano era liberal, católico, municipal y centroamericanista a la vez. Pero todavía no era democracia moderna: sufragio censitario, elecciones indirectas, participación popular restringida.
Ana: Entonces la segunda taza nos deja una conclusión sobria: la Costa Rica independiente nace con vocación jurídica, pero no plenamente democrática. Construye Estado de derecho, sí; pero todavía con exclusiones fuertes.
Mateo: Y deja planteado el siguiente giro: cuando el café se vuelva el motor económico, el Estado liberal tendrá recursos para codificar, educar, construir caminos y también para revelar sus propios límites.